haha hello freak bitches it just doesn't
seem like a huge product gets everybody
gets their phone ruined by pouring a
drink on it like that's the number one
reason phones get ruined i would say i
would say cracked screens toilet I'll
take cracked screens are probably higher
than water but they're both high speed
of cat cracked screens cracked screen is
almost universal right doesn't everybody
get a crack screen I've never had one
eye but I've had to move a turd to get
my phone out out of the toilet did you
kill the phone or the phone survive have
fun survive how long was it in Russia to
webmail litter it literally like I got
up and then it fell in the toilet now we
look at put my hand through or instant
grabbed it pulled it out and then and
then uh just write it off if you put on
the bag of rice no he didn't even wash
his hands as fuck no I did the shaky
thing and that was good enough though
hairdryer oh really what you should do
if that happens is 24 hours in a bag of
rice yeah it'll it'll pull away with
moisture what I usually end up just
doing is then having something stop
working and then take it to the apple or
call the apple store and they will send
you one with that he apples great with
that here's the weird thing though they
put or at least they used to I don't
know anymore I used to do like some
repairs on these things crack them open
and get crazy like that but they used to
put little litmus paper in there that
would show or got wet it will turn red
he used to be in the headphone jack I
don't know they probably are still do it
I still do it like that but if you call
they don't there's no way from this
check well here's a question when when
you say if you drop something in the
toilet you drop a phone the topic should
you shut it off and throw it in the bag
of rice or should you leave behind it
turns itself off but yeah if you if it's
still on turner turner okay luckily it
shut off yeah so shut it off yep throw
it in a bag of rice yeah what i usually
do just suck the water out of it oh but
but but but i wasn't going to do with
the poop ones right yeah why not it's
gross because when you suck it off if
you look at your iphone like there's the
top part where the this this where your
ear usually goes but there's water
that's in there so you suck that and
you're like pretty much sucking earwax
it's gross I never I never thought of
talking on my phone ever bump into that
well like I go like really hard many
times have you done
product five times so where's your fault
with where you're going that you're
getting ear wax on that if you look if
you look there's like a little grill
that's right there if you look really
close you could actually see their shit
in there I was thinking about the jack
itself now you have to suck all of them
there's the bottom one that you suck
it's like the power but does that work
can you really suck the water out will
it really helped it's what I always
don't you mean they don't getting water
away from it is gonna be a positive
thing but but it's a guy on the phone is
I customary see yes dude listen I've
been sucking on my phones that cool I'm
just shitting in the most polite way
possible I wouldn't recommend it now
well and that's a problem because we've
we've capitalized and privatize the
education system to hear such a degree I
mean if you get a degree in Australia
where it's Macquarie University or
sydney university or university of new
south wales it's an MBA one of those
schools is exactly same as an MBA than
one of those schools here you know you
at not only does an MBA matter that also
and then it has to be from the right
school so an MBA from Harvard or an Ivy
League school is Trump's and MBA from
university of san diego or something
like that and that shouldn't be the way
and in fact what that does it still
keeps propelling that plutocracy because
there's a study done that at least for
every student at harvard each student in
have it has at least one parent earning
at least four hundred thousand dollars
per year so we're still you know with
the capitalization of everything we're
we're forming a system where we have you
know the very wealthy at the top and we
have everybody struggling at the bottom
that the elitism involved in education
is really fascinating to me today
especially because there's so much
access to information so many books so
much online so much to read and just you
could get so much access to information
that would you know a long time ago the
difference between going to Harvard and
going to San Diego State was pretty
gigantic but what with what you have
access to today the average person has
access to the exact same from
information that they're teaching at any
school anywhere yeah but I had a
conversation with a friend of mine and
he was wrong about something and I
brought up this woman who
had you know she went to the University
of Mississippi but she went there and
this was her major like this thing that
she would that we were talking about and
he goes well this guy went to Yale you
know but he didn't even go to Yale for
that he went to Yale for something else
and he's 80 okay so he went to Yale in
like the 1960s who knows what the fuck
they were teaching back then like what
are you talking about man you know like
but the ideas first initial reaction was
look she went to the University of
Mississippi he went to Yale oh that's
hilarious but that is the way we think
in this country it is and also not only
is the way we think but you know these
kids that are going to MIT or Harvard or
Yale well it's the networks they take
with them so when it the jobs are avail
you know the only growth area that we
have in this country is a technology
jobs but that's such an inch Allah job
market where only the network's the
alumni from these prestigious schools
get to really apply from it all the kids
working at Google they all in today's
you know fancy schools it could be
afforded by the wealthy parents Colin
quit a long time ago remind many many
years where first I gonna open out that
I was dating a british girl and she was
a real pervert like I drove a Saturn
back then I still lived in Jersey and I
used to fucking park outside a
danger-filled and she would blow me I
would trap she liked me to trap her head
under my steering wheel and she'd go
like I want you to bite me I want you to
bite me like she would repeat this oh
this a mantra of me biting her on her
back but she like to be bitten and
brutalized so I would bite her back and
she would like how much to make me suck
it and I would hold her head under the
wheel and she'll be trapped under my
saturn steering wheel and fucking she
would suck my dick and lick my balls
whatever good kid she was a good girl
yeah her name is Ruth she was a really
cool girl Ruth yeah good five and talk
to her in 15 years but she was a great
girl I miss her terribly I think she
went back across the pond hello as they
say and I've always the point of the
story Oh Colin she was really loud when
I ate her pussy I'm really super loud
and it was fluid she said I don't
remember just moaning and groaning yeah
Jimmy what what are those things yeah
why tips yeah yeah yeah he said whatever
it was I be a hooligan with my shine
oh yeah yeah me bake my pussy like its
Manchester United universe but I can't
it was a really loud and your pussy was
sloppy fucking wet like it was legit
hahahahaha like I knew she wasn't
putting on a show cause her pussy was
sloppy I was getting eat her pussy on
the air OPI dear this before I was ill I
get every day and opiate said calling
your pussy on the air and I was gonna do
that and Colin Quinn stop me and you
know and he goes you can do that you
could put man your comic you gotta say
funny shit you don't want to be that guy
that does wacky things and I'm like I
never forgot that he was almost telling
me don't be a stunt boy you gotta say it
funny you got to sit there and be funny
verbally and I may be in that case he
was right because I wasn't the gunner
wacko who called up at eight pussy on
the air it's like I have to be able to
be funny in my delivery and say another
yeah it was kind of a good point looking
back in hindsight I probably should have
eaten her pussy on the air should be a
very funny clip